Hi, Internet,
Recently, YouTube invited me to California for a very interesting party with a bunch
people. They talked a lot and played with the balloons, but most of all, there was a debate about how it might look
the future of education - which is no small thing, because how the company educates its next
the future of human civilization determines the generation of scientists, doctors, and programmers.
It was amazing for days. And, though disorderly, I would like to share with you a few
my thoughts on the subject. And as someone who taught both in schools and beyond.
This is what schools always looked like: a lord in front who knows everything
and students who know nothing, so the gentleman is telling them.
But the teacher explains the pace that suits one student.
All others are bored because they have long since understood or are lost,
because they lack the knowledge they should already have.
At the end of the lesson, no matter whether the students understood the substance, with others
and another substance.
And it doesn't matter if the teachers use chalkboard, felt-tip pens or smart board, and whether students
use tables, paper or tablets - the system does not change - it just
technology does the same in shiny form.
But the internet is different and in the background there are interesting things that happen
indicate the direction in which education will evolve.
In an ideal school, every student has a lecturer like Alexander the Great
Aristotle.
But if your educational policy is "Aristotle for Everyone" then you have three
problems:
1) There are not enough people in the world to teach each child individually, and if they are,
it would be incredibly expensive. If workforce and money were not a problem,
it remains the fact that not everyone is as good a lecturer as Aristotle.
But technology solves these problems: let's start with 1:
Who needs people when everything can teach you the internet?
You want to learn integrals: so start.
Do you need a biology course? Try this one - along with hundreds of thousands more
students.
The Internet is significantly expanding the audience of potential teachers and solving the problem of working
forces.
But it is not the celebration of the internet that I have just complained about: new
technician does old stuff, just looks better? After all, if you grew up in front of the Internet
and you were a little curious, there was always a place where you could learn everything you wanted.
In addition, radio and television were thought to be a revolution in education. By
that allows teachers to reach the masses. But the revolution did not come.
These are good objections, but the Internet is much better off solving the cost problem
than radio and TV.
TV shows are expensive, and even the best ones are often pushed out by more stupid and
more popular shows that are also - not by chance - more profitable.
This is known as the "History Channel" effect.
But the cost of internet access is constantly falling, as is the cost of producing content
for the Internet.
Which is why a paper guy and a marker in his room can reach a million views
per month at essentially zero cost and does not have to worry about competition from the side
this.
So the internet solves problems one and two, but educational videos aren't
individualized, which makes YouTube just a video library and not an Aristotle-style tutor.
But we can build on YouTube, the future I see as follows: Digital Aristotle pro
everyone.
A program that teaches students individually by selecting videos from YouTube,
a program that tests students based on what they already know, and especially the program they do
it adapts the teaching according to how effective the videos and tests are
and scientifically verifying which work best.
It's not a utopia. Already there are people who work on different aspects (even though Digital Aristotle
is not their explicit goal). One such place is the Khan Academy, which is more than
only Sal's calming voice. "If you're not paf from this, then you have no emotions." For
this website hides complex software testing everything about student progress:
the effectiveness of different videos and tests, different ways of asking questions.
Today it may seem primitive, but technology is constantly improving. Up to Digital Aristotle
it will be cheaper, less laborious and better than human teachers can ever
be.
I often hear the argument that Digital Aristotle (or something like that) frees teachers who
they will be able to walk through the classroom and help children work on interesting projects - and even though
this may happen in the near future, I don't think it would be true in the longer term.
Because what happens when Digital Aristotle knows students better than a teacher? When
in every field of human activity, the best and brightest can go on
on the way of knowledge, and better than a teacher could ever have?
I doubt that schools will disappear - after all, they're not just here for learning but also
They allow parents to engage in the economy while their children are transformed
to civilized adults. But schools will change radically - there will be fewer teachers in them
who will do less and less.
This is not good news for teachers, but it is a great news for the company.
If you are now a student with poor results, the school goes on without you, and if you excel,
school is holding you back.
In my opinion, everyone in the future will use Digital Aristotle throughout their lives - a personal tutor,
who will teach them exactly what they need to learn and when they are best prepared. AND
when it comes, we will have both - a better education system and a better society.
I want to thank YouTube EDU and the people who have led him to invite him to California
to meet these amazing people. I've done more interesting interviews for several
than I normally do in a few months.
If you want to see what the best educational videos look like, go and see their channels
and if you want to hear more, I put together a playlist on the subject
you might like.